[Musica]
in quanti qua dentro lavorano nella
comunicazione alzate la mano la tela ma
bravi tutti gli altri possono andare voi
che avete alzato la mano ritenetevi i
miei ostaggi devo dirvi una cosa un paio
di cose faccio una premessa metto le
mani avanti io sono uno di voi
anch'io sono un comunicatore io gestisco
un sito internet una pagina facebook
sono autore televisivo e speaker alla
radio quindi anch'io come voi vivo la
vita nella costante corsa all'evitare il
contatto con un lavoro vero e quindi
siamo uniti nella stessa battaglia voi
elio grazie di questo freud ma c'è un ma
è che non so come dirvelo ma io cari
comunicatori io vi odio vi odio ed
essendo uno di voi io odio me stesso è
un dilemma interiore che mi divora da
tantissimi anni e per questo sono qui
per riportare tutti con i piedi per
terra ho percepito oggi tanto entusiasmo
qua dentro troppo entusiasmo se posso
dire totalmente immotivato totalmente i
motivi a partire dal titolo di questo
the bigs mettiamo l'uomo al centro della
società ecco io a questa cosa non ci
credo poi tanto cioè io la fiducia
nell'uomo nell'umanità l'ho persa oramai
da tanto tempo posso anche dirvi quando
ero ragazzino e vi dico la verità me la
sono andata un po a cercare perché
mentre i miei amici giocavano a basket
si compravano la mountain bike
oppure imparavano a suonare il piano o
la chitarra io michelle sy un altro
hobby e decisi di fare l'arbitro di
calcio
dirò soltanto che negli anni della mia
adolescenza
ho ricevuto una quantità di insulti
improperi e minacce di morte che io la
boldrini e saviano ce la giochiamo sul
filo di lana
non temo il confronto con nessuno
io facevo la prima superiore e passavo
le domeniche su un campo a sentirmi
gridare devi morire da uomini e donne
che avevano l'età dei miei genitori
lo capite che il lunedì quando tornavo a
scuola e venivo bulli dato dai miei
compagni per me era comunque un sollievo
rispetto a quello che passavo domenica e
perché vi racconto queste cose per due
motivi il primo non è colpa di facebook
mettiamo le cose in chiaro non è colpa
di facebook questo era il 94 eravamo
stronzi anche prima
ok non è colpa di facebook e poi secondo
motivo per chi tra voi e genitore
mandate il vostro figlio a vostra figlia
fare l'arbitro di qualsiasi sport non è
un consiglio così buttato lì è vero
arbitrale si imparano tantissime cose si
impara a osservare si impara a prendere
decisioni in fretta si impara a
recuperare mentalmente dai propri errori
e soprattutto si impara qual è il numero
dei carabinieri da chiamare quando sei
chiuso nello spogliatoio
e i tifosi ti aspettano fuori anzi
fatelo voi
l'arbitro per una partita sola provateci
anche a livello amatoriale utilissimo
soprattutto per chi lavora nella
comunicazione cioè tutti voi perché
anche se non avete alzato la mano io lo
so e lo sapete anche voi che ci siamo
dentro tutti oggi l'uomo è costretto
anzi condannato a essere un comunicatore
anche e soprattutto l'arbitro di calcio
perché tu quando all'ultimo minuto in un
campo di periferia sullo 0 a 0 fischi un
rigore e sei circondato da undici uomini
che vogliono farti ingoiare il
fischietto eccoli qualcosa glielo devi
raccontare se vuole uscirne vivo ed è
così che si diventa comunicatori per
sopravvivere nei millenni l'uomo è
diventato cacciatore pastore poi
agricoltore sempre per lo stesso motivo
per sopravvivere
e oggi è diventato comunicatore sempre
per sopravvivere perché oggi qualunque
sia il tuo lavoro saper comunicare le
cose che fai è diventato importante
quanto saperle fare anzi di più di più
perché non serve a niente fare le cose
se poi non le sai comunicare con un
linguaggio efficace e ficcante
coinvolgente soprattutto nella politica
dove si è perso completamente qualsiasi
senso della misura
dove oggi uno può svegliarsi dire una
frase tipo
abbiamo abolito la povertà senza che
nessuno lo prenda a scappellotti sul
collo qua dietro forte perché oggi non
si può dire abbiamo messo un po di soldi
in tasca di chi se la passa tanto bene
non se la passa tanto bene sentite
questa frase come arrendevole come
perdente no non basta oggi devi dire
abbiamo abolito la povertà non importa
se non è vero importa che funziona e
funziona perché io quando l'ho sentito
ho preso una carta da 100 euro medi sono
acceso un sigaro
abbiamo abolito la povertà funziona
basta che funzioni
basta che funzioni perché oggi saper
raccontare le cose è più importante di
saperle fare e quando sei veramente
bravo quando le cose le sai raccontare
veramente bene allora le cose non c'è
neanche più bisogno di farle le racconti
e basta il passo definitivo non fare
niente raccontare che stai facendo tutto
se l'abbiamo tutti un amico un collega
che è così e di solito ha fatto più
carriera di noi non fare niente
raccontare che stai facendo tutto è
difficile ma se sei bravo
ci puoi riuscire per un po ad esempio
puoi dire a tutti può raccontare a tutti
che sai fare la migliore amatriciana del
mondo anche se non hai mai cucinato in
vita tua
basta non invitare mai nessuno
nessuno ti verrà mai a smascherare
oppure puoi pensare più in grande puoi
inventarti da zero un ristorante che non
esiste e con l'aiuto di alcuni amici che
ti scrivono recensioni fasulle farlo
arrivare al primo posto su tripadvisor
nella classifica di ristoranti di londra
questa notizia è vera ha fatto il giro
del mondo
questo ristorante di scelta ed un which
non esiste non è mai esistito primo su
18 mila ristoranti di londra su
tripadvisor e la gente telefonava diceva
vorrei un tavolo mi dispiace non c'è
posto è certo che non c'è posto non c'è
neanche il ristorante all'ora come la
chiamiamo questa ottima comunicazione
oppure truffa rispondete tutte e due
sedi e tutte e due vuol dire che sono
sinonimi attenzione mi state dicendo voi
che la comunicazione tanto più efficace
quanto più è indistinguibile dalla
truffa ma che silenzio che si è fatto
adesso è questa truffa ha un nome la
parola che si sta rendendo tutti quanti
schiavi story telling moriremo di
storytelling ory remo di tori termini è
inutile che applaudiamo dovevate
dovevamo sospettarlo fin dal principio
perché se c'è una cosa che ho imparato è
che quando dal nulla
esce fuori un espressione inglese e mi
scuso con tutti gli inglesi in sala che
sono tanti da qualche parte c'è la
fregatura
facciamo un po di esempi jobs act
spending review fiscal compact light
lunch conference call tutte fregature
soprattutto conference call
story telling la narrazione emozionale a
qualsiasi costo va bene per tutto va
bene in qualsiasi campo alta anche a un
genio l'ha detto benissimo in una
vignetta
la narrazione emozionale a ogni costo si
applica indiscriminatamente a qualsiasi
campo al racconto delle partite di
calcio come a quello delle cialde del
caffè come l'ultimo modello di suv
oppure il cibo per cani
vuoi vendere un cibo per cani non basta
dire che è sano e nutriente no
oggi devi dire così alimenterà
l'orgoglio di esseri animali a ridete
adesso questo spot è tuttora in onda
l'abbiamo visto tutti e non ci facciamo
caso alimenta la loro voglia di essere
animali fermiamoci un istante
immaginiamoci la scena c'è il tuo cane
in poltrona con le zampe accavallate
sorseggia un brandy fuma la pipa legge
un libro e tu sei lì che lo guardi e fai
oggi fufi non ha proprio voglia di
essere animale come posso fare
fogli dai pro cantini lui mangia gli
viene voglia di altro animale butta via
tutte correa trombarsi della gamma del
tavolino
questa è la pubblicità oggi voi ridete
voi vivete voi ridete ma questi messaggi
funzionano e funzionano principalmente
per un motivo perché abbiamo smesso di
ascoltarli sono troppi il bombardamento
di messaggi e stimoli arriva ogni
secondo e sono troppi non riusciamo più
ascoltarli allora il cervello sviluppato
gli anticorpi per ignorarli e fateci
caso la nostra soglia di attenzione oggi
è così bassa per questo motivo perché
ascoltare tutti i messaggi che ci
arrivano da ogni direzione sarebbe
insostenibile e il comunicatore quello
che questi messaggi li ha scritti lo sa
lo sa che non li ascoltiamo un po ci
spera e gli fa comodo e gli fa comodo
perché allora vuol dire che non deve
impegnarsi neanche lui più di tanto
uno fa il lavoro che faccio io cerca di
scrivere un pezzo comico si arrovella
tutta una giornata non gli viene una
battuta poi accende la tv alimenta la
loro voglia di essere animali bingo è
meraviglioso questo dovrebbe prendere in
giro la comicità questo dovrebbe
prendere in giro la cosiddetta satira le
cose insensate che diciamo per fare
pubblicità che sia
con cibo per cani a un partito politico
o a noi stessi non prendere di mira
queste cose in radio in tv ma nessuno lo
fa perché perché non si può e perché le
aziende gli inserzionisti partner non si
può vorresti dire delle cose ma non puoi
e allora ti arrabbi spegni la tv esce di
casa mi serve dell'area nuova vado a
fare una passeggiata
esco di casa e trovo ogni santo giorno
sotto casa mia un negozio che ha davanti
alla porta questo cartello fuori dalla
vetrina ma tu sano di mente può
iscrivere eliminazione totale bambino
fuori dal tuo negozio che poi uno si fa
anche delle illusioni 1 porta il bambino
questo pretesto una vendita promozionale
ci rimane malissimo
vabbè ma questo lo perdoniamo una
comunicazione artigianale un negozio se
l'ha stampato da solo è un lapsus oppure
no pure l'ha fatto apposta
oppure lui sapeva che sarebbe finito sui
social e in questa slide allora ha vinto
lui e io sono suo complice anzi ora che
ci penso è davvero così era una
provocazione
apro una parentesi ci avete fatto caso
che oggi non si c'è quasi più è una
minchiata ma è una provocazione
l'ultima provocazione delta l'artista
l'ultima provocazione dello stilista
l'ultima provocazione del tal quotidiano
sappiamo tutti quali quotidiano l'ultima
provocazione dell'attrice della cantante
provocazione le provocazioni finiscono
sui giornali diventano notizie noi
eleggiamo e ci crediamo e allora hanno
vinto loro noi ancora una volta siamo
complici e magari accanto alla
provocazione sul giornale c'è anche una
pubblicità così il nostro mutuo è
vegetariano
ora qualcuno che ha studiato lettere per
favore mi spieghi che figura retorica è
mutuo vegetariano una sinestesia è la
più brutta sinestesia mai coniata sulla
faccia della terra mutuo vegetariano con
la coppietta li felice con le verdurine
allegra mutuo vegetariano ma io non
riesco a odiare fino in fondo questa
pubblicità di una banca nazionale per un
motivo perché molte volte il messaggio
vero lo si dice senza volerlo perché la
verità è che quando tu hai firmato un
mutuo tutto ciò che potrai permetterti
di mangiare
stato quel tavolo di roma lo capisco
mutuo vegetariano perché perché la moda
il salutismo il mangiare sano va bene ci
posso stare
va bene è sacrosanto dire che stai
usando ingredienti naturali
quando sei un'azienda alimentare va bene
ma anche in questo caso a volte secondo
me c'è qualcuno che si fa prendere
troppo la mano ed esagera
io sono una persona semplice ok a medici
cento per cento di frutta mi accontento
non chiedo non ti chiedo altro non ti
chiedo altro ma perché ti iscrivi di più
e soprattutto cos'è questo di più c'è
più materia di quanto possa contenerne e
anche qui centro di neutrini c'è
qualcosa io ho paura ad aprirlo perché
prendono potrebbe scatenarsi un buco
nero che fa collassare l'intera cucina
la risucchia dentro chiude il cento per
cento
non so voi ma io questo va detto non lo
apro vivevo piuttosto un bicchiere di
vino per esempio di questa bottiglia che
mi hanno regalato degli amici ecco qui
avete riso ma l'amico che mi ha regalato
questa bottiglia mi ha spiegato una cosa
e giuro che è tutto vero
le case vinicole molto spesso per
agevolare la fermentazione usano li
eviti di origine animale perché costano
meno ecco che questa etichetta
perfettamente senso bene ho imparato
qualcosa non lo sapevo ma allora per
quale motivo e io ve lo giuro
la stessa bottiglia a sull'etichetta
posteriore questa scritta consigliato
per gustare carne rossa brasa
lo avete capito
l'avete capito perché vi odio e qui
veniamo all'appello che voglio farvi
aziende agenzie comunicatore di tutto il
mondo per favore un po meno o meno
comunichiamo un po meglio e un po meno
ma soprattutto un po meno
dovremo pagare ogni parola che usiamo
come si fa per i telegrammi dovremmo
prendere esempio da uno dei più grandi
poeti italiani ungaretti le avete
scritte tutte le sue poesie no ungaretti
ungaretti poco più di cento anni fa sul
carso durante la prima guerra mondiale
in trincea lui scriveva queste parole
quando trovo in questo mio silenzio una
parola scavata è nella mia vita come un
abisso lui nella pausa tra un
bombardamento e l'altro scavava nel
silenzio per trovare una parola una sola
che valesse la pena di essere scritte
oggi cosa facciamo oggi al contrario
oggi ci tocca scavare tra le parole per
trovare del silenzio ma il bombardamento
è troppo forte non si ferma mai non ce
la facciamo non troviamo più questo
silenzio ci siamo disabituati
completamente anche all'idea del
silenzio persino durante i minuti di
silenzio negli stadi
noi applaudiamo pur di fare qualcosa pur
di non sostenere il nostro stesso
silenzio
pensiamoci un po di più a ungaretti che
è l'uomo che scrisse queste parole che
tutti conoscete si sta come d'autunno
sugli alberi le foglie cento anni fa
le parole più belle più dense più
significative mai scritte per definire
la precarietà della condizione di un
soldato durante la guerra e dopo cento
anni sono ancora lì immortali e sono
nove parole e noi che siamo gli eredi di
ungaretti dopo 100 anni come gli
rispondiamo
[Applauso]
sapete però sapete però che vista così
non è mai
e qui veniamo a quello che voglio dirvi
che un po di silenzio
ogni tanto è bellissimo e lo dico a voi
per dirlo a me stesso perché sono il
primo a cui costa fatica e capisco che
sia paradossale che queste parole
arrivino dopo un pomeriggio così fitto è
così pieno di parole ma se vogliamo
mettere l'uomo al centro della società
dobbiamo innanzitutto per seguire il
valore alle parole stituire peso alle
parole non sprecarle non buttarle via
teniamoci ogni tanto qualche tweet non
diamo pareri su tutto ciò che accade nel
mondo non serve teniamocelo per noi quel
commento cattivo che abbiamo scritto su
facebook col ghigno tra i denti andando
fieri di noi stessi teniamolo per noi
teniamo per noi le liti le lamentele
teniamo per noi il sarcasmo a tutti i
costi facciamo un po di silenzio fatelo
anche voi adesso lo sentite
questo è il suono celestiale di una
persona che ha un'opinione e se la tiene
per sé è bellissimo
e mentre stiamo in silenzio magari
esercitiamo un po di quell'attività così
fuori moda come l'ascolto l'empatia la
comprensione e la condivisione perché se
vogliamo rimetterci al centro della
società prima dobbiamo metterci un po
defilati ad ascoltare se continua a
parlarci addosso non ci muoveremo mai di
un passo dal punto in cui siamo a questo
non è esseri umani non rinchiudiamo c i
nostri preconcetti nei pregiudizi
soffochiamo non accontentiamoci di
quello che crediamo di sapere
facciamo noi stessi un grande regalo
alimentiamo la nostra voglia di essere
umani
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]